- So I was like, “Bro, he didn’t throw my clothes in the shower, bro.”
So I’mma, I’m about to fight this man. And now that—and uh, I was cryin’.
I’m like, I’m cryin’. I’m like, “That man too big to be fightin’,”
you know what I’m sayin’?
[Both laughing]
So, I’m like, man.
♪♪♪
- Jamaal Charles.
- Jamaal, baby. What it do?
- How you doin’?
- Nothin’, man.
- Congratulations on retirement, man.
- [Jamaal Charles:] ‘Preciate it.
Now I’m about to retire you on these pool sticks, man.
- [Master Tesfatsion:] Oh, is that right?
Jamaal, you had some incredible years with the Kansas City Chiefs.
What are some memorable stories that you may have
with either Andy Reid or Larry Johnson?
- Yeah, I got plenty of, uh, Larry Johnson, man, uh.
- Start me off with Larry then.
- Oh, man.
- I need somethin’ from Larry.
- Man, Larry treated me like a, a brother when I got to know him.
But, like, when I first knew him, it was,
it was—my rookie year was kind of rough.
You know, when you come in, you get a lot of haze as a rookie coming up.
So, it was my rookie year.
Uh, you had to bring food to, to the veteran guys.
So, I forgot to bring food one week.
And, uh, and it’s my first time really seeing Larry get outrageous.
[Laughing]
“Where’s my lunch at?! Where’s my lunch at?!”
And I’m like, “Aww, man.” So I’m like, “Man, ahh, I’ll get you next time!”
So I thought, you know what I’m saying,
I thought he would just let it go.
And next practice came—coming in I was like, “I had a good practice!”
Smiling, laughing, everything, man.
Go in my locker, I be like—boy, I be like, “Ooh!”
Cuz I know, I know ’em. Every, every week they was gettin’ somebody.
They was gettin’, they, they was gettin’—
- What’d he do to you, man? What’d he do to you?!
- I get in the shower, and I’m like, “Who they got today?”
I be like, “Aw, man, that look familiar right there.
Them clothes look familiar right there!”
I’m like, “Nah, that can’t be my clothes, man.”
- When did you realize that was your clothes?
- I keep telling myself: “It better not be my clothes.”
[Laughing]
So I was like, “Bro, he didn’t throw my clothes in the shower, bro.”
So I’mma, I’m about to fight this man.
And now that—and, uh, I was cryin’. I’m like, I’m cryin’.
I’m like, “That man too big to be fightin’,” you know what I’m sayin’?
[Master laughing]
So, I’m like, “Man, I ain't know if I'mma fight him.”
So I call everybody, try to convince them to talk me out of it.
I ain’t gonna really fight him.
“Mom, I’m about to fight him!”
“Don’t fight him!” “Oh, all right, Mom! I’ll call you back.”
I called my girlfriend: “I’m about to fight him!”
And as you know, I like, that calmed me down.
I was like, man, “OK, I’m about to hit him in the head with his helmet.”
She said: “Don’t do that, Jamaal.”
- What’d you wear outta the locker room then?
- [Jamaal:] Um, I had gave my, my clothes to give the equipment guy to dry off.
Ah, man, I was just sittin’ down with my little towel on.
[Master laughing]
Man, my little towel on my little stool.
So I had to wait to get dried off.
[Both laughing]
How long it takes to get the clothes, what? About 40 minutes? About 45?
- Mmhmm.
- I had to wait a good ol’, in a, with a towel—with a towel around my waist.
[Master laughing]
So I’m in this, I’m in the, I’m the only one there, sittin’ there.
Everybody went home.
I’m, I’m waitin’ for my clothes to get dried off by the equipment guy.
It was a good time to get in that playbook by the time—
[Both laughing]
But I, I didn’t feel bad because a couple weeks later
he slashes one of my homeboy’s tires cuz he didn’t bring no food.
- [Master:] What?
- [Jamaal:] Michael Cox—he can tell you to this day.
Man, he probably—he probably still mad.
[Master laughing]
You know what I’m sayin’?
But, uh, I was like, “Man, we gotta stop playin’ with this man.
This man, he gonna, he, he makin’ us pay one way or another.
If you don’t wanna pay for food,
you gonna make it—you gonna have to pay somewhere else.
So I was like, you gotta bring him some,
uh, some Shipley Do-Nuts.
Whatever you want—Denny’s? OK.
[Master laughing]
Every going-away trip, if he got a Subway sandwich, I got a Subway sandwich.
So I’m eating like him too.
[Both laughing]
After I saw that, it took me one time—
it always take me one time to learn my lessons.
[Both laughing]
- Thanks for kickin' it with us.
Subscribe to B/R to check out more dope videos like this one.